mr. julianne hough is Ulster bound and
how gorgeous is she gonna look in her
gown I love my shape because it's nobody
else's it's mine I work hard for it
she's totally given us AB envy but
Julianne admit she had an unhealthy body
image saying quote when I look at
pictures of myself when I was 19 my body
was bangin but I was killing myself I
was working out two and a half hours a
day and eatin the bare minimum to
survive I was so miserable the 28 year
old actress singer a dancer is on the
cover of September shape magazine and
even though she still does hardcore
workouts five times a week
she doesn't deny herself pizza she says
quote I eat it a lot I think that your
body is your body and you should own it
and you should love it
Julianne is now busy planning her
wedding to fiancé hockey player Brooks
alike but she still does find that time
to hit the gym I don't think I look for
any one person to inspire me to get up
and work out I think actually about my
future self what I would want to feel
like when I'm you know ten years down
the line or if I'm starting to have kids
you